ready what'd you do anything you don't
like that whoa pull it down
[Music]
oh hey you got a day long legs on your
hand let me take a peek at him well
yeah he likes ya he's a friendly spider
yeah he's not that friendly fire but he
wanted to kill him
Oh Nathan wanted to kill the day long
leg Oh
Nathan you got a fever jelly sandwich oh
good
got a carbo-load I don't get my
underwater with my your pet spiders huh
yeah you're white honky Tyrell what do
you got there Tommy oh is that your swim
bait boy that's the same one that got
thrown into the trout pond at Bass Pro
Shop
[Music]
are you feeling here a rock no approach
Monday I just need you in the same day I
have time hey Rosie oh no no tell me can
you demonstrate your dog whistle yeah
you're not strong enough to live that
you know pull that no by yourself yeah
are they moving
here's Nathan hold this then they'll
hold it hold it Dobie - Logan Square and
hold it Nathan hold it you hold it hey
[Applause]
[Music]
there's something blocking those you see
in the hole I did not warn you look look
I start on me I said my god my eyes I
want to work in it all you got something
in your eye time to go was I going to
give mommy a big hug goes on then he
doesn't want to take that NAEP
yeah you down with NAB yeah you and me
you down with that Navy yeah you and me